what will add to two strategies before
well we have two strategies that we've
been using yep number one clay liked
herbs number two simply my good now yeah
look at this we can do these things
where there's something else we have to
do before we can connect the like
turning we have to expand right good so
let's take both sides and expand it
let's do that we can do this the fives
got to say huh girl over to the H and
led to the negative three good all the
right-hand side careful three times to H
so it's gonna be six H minus three well
done okay now hard of a second after we
expand yeah now we've got exactly what
we've had in the previous question the
light you see what I mean do you see
what I mean that so much now that's is
can many problems that you don't know
how to solve into ones you stood at us
all and we could do this what was the
question on the phone
all right walk through this with me
let's do the collecting of lactose
you've done this a few times let's see
if we can do it faster instead of doing
it one at a time
let's move the H's subtract the HS and
get rid of the numbers okay so five H
over here and six H over here
what should I do both sighing - I should
subtract 6 H 6 H so when you subtract it
from that 5 8 - 6 H how many HSN card
left - May - name - H good ok now then
you have these guys right negative 15
here negative 3 here which side do you
want the numbers to be on I wanted to
know the right I want I want the lettuce
via the numbers over here right be
careful sir in other words yeah listen
carefully in other words I want to get
rid of this negative 15 how do I do it
if I - it'll be even more - all right so
I should plus I should
I should add to get rid of all fifty
exactly I want zero what's negative
three plus 15
negative three plus 15
that's positive twelve isn't it what
have we done I've gotten down to this
line we've just done it all at once
okay and that's an okay thing to do can
you see what happened
the 6h this is what Jack was referred to
before the 6h I have subtracted from
both sides
it became nothing over here and it
became minus H over here and then I
added 15 to both sides it kids with that
and it became this when when you take
away three now I have to do I have to
get rid of the minus and the ways I can
either divide or multiply both sides by
negative one the negative over here will
cancel you just get H the day you will
just become